the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
last time we talked about attention and
the idea that attention is got some
properties we're very limited in what we
can focus on we attend to less than we
might guess in our environment on the
other hand there are channels of
information that sneak into us
unconsciously with minimal attention and
that experimental research has kind of
shown us what requires our focus
attention to be noticed and what can
sneak in through pathways things like
features in our environment and so I
want to talk to you today about two
kinds of spectacular disorders of
attention and and and in a higher level
vision and insights they give us into
the brain basis of attention and again
the message is how much we construct by
the rules of our mind and brain the
environment that we see around us so
we'll talk about blind sights that's a
great name
the paradoxical state that people are
cortically blind but they kind of
perceive some things we'll talk about
that what is it what do we know about
the brain basis what system of
unconscious perception might occur you
know be in our brains in these patients
is there only visual system in you and I
it's something in us and we don't know
exactly what is doing relative to our
conscious visual system but we have the
same brain system available to us and
then neglect what it is it's brain basis
and how it teaches us again how we
construct the world around us to know
what space were in and what's around us
so a reminder I think you know this well
by now that the world out there is
divided into a left and right visual
field as we look forward in the middle
that the information from the left
visual field goes through your brain and
ended up shown in the right primary
visual cortex from the right visual
field into your left primary visual
cortex but there's one other pathway we
haven't talked about a very much which
goes to your structure called the
superior colliculus it's part of your
midbrain and it's what the system we
think gives rise to the possibility of
sensation without perception and that
phrase sensation without perception is
that we want to describe blind sight and
we'll describe it in a moment so from
your retina where all vision has to go
through a little bit of information a
small number of fibers go to a part of
your
bring the controls your pupillary
reflexes you know what makes you people
get wider or smaller to see 90% of the
fibers coming you know nerve fibers had
to come from your eye and go through the
lateral geniculate are through the major
system that you heard about from melissa
that connect to your primary visual
cortex and then there's one other small
visual pathway from the retina to this
superior colliculus sometimes called a
techno Palvin or a system such a small
pathway from your eyes in terms of the
number of four nerve fibers and so
people said well can we say what's not
done by the major visual pathway that
goes from from the eye to the cortex
what's done by this other small pathway
and one of the ways I looked at
originally all the way back in 1881 was
to create in dog's bilateral occipital
lesions so did another cortically blind
do not retina blind they're cortically
plants in the cortex and what can these
animals do and they were very impressed
that all those animals didn't recognize
many things they could steer their way
around their environment they wouldn't
bump into things if you had a blindfold
on or if you were retina ly blind and
weren't given any opportunity to know
your environment you would bump into
things right but these animals seem to
steer their way around things pretty
well and they can do some other very
simple tasks even though they ought to
have been seeing nothing so this is a
suggestion in animals that there's
something in the brains of primates that
gives you some information that doesn't
go through your conscious cortex and
then a number of patient studies in
patients with naturally occurring
injuries have really shown us given us a
chance to experiment on them in a human
and relate them to human experience so
here's a patient who had a large injury
a large bleed in the right visual cortex
so because of this this patient this man
was blind in the left visual field this
field was fine this field was blind
cortically blind and the way that people
figure out in what way are you blind
what parts of the world do you see and
do you not see is they'll put you in
front of a computer monitor and they'll
turn on lights and various locations and
they'll create a map like this which
you where you respond when a light comes
on and where you don't sue it so your
job basically you just look in the
middle and you say push a button when a
light comes on you're waiting and light
comes on somewhere on the monitor and so
what this picture is showing you so the
person could respond when the lights
came on anywhere on the left side but
never responded never said a light came
on
on the right side people call this
perimetry it's a it's a standard
neurological test of visual difficulty
here's a person whose injury harms only
a quadrant of their visual thing so they
never respond when a light turns on in
that quarter of the world out there but
the other 3/4 they respond to so that's
a way of testing what are you doing
you're not asking them anything
sophisticated just to the light come on
is that okay so for this patient here's
the mapping this patient was fine in the
right visual field this is one eye this
is the other eye and terrible with a few
spots a little bit better because
lesions occurring naturally in people
are seldom perfect lesions but you can
see that all this area that's dark our
areas that when a light came on in the
left visual field this man never
responded that anything had turned on
there's nothing simpler right than light
turning on and off he did not experience
anything turning on in that way on the
left half of the world so but they
noticed as they gave this test that even
when he was saying I don't see anything
nothing's happening that when they
flashed something in that blind
cortically blind field he would sort of
move his eyes in that direction all
right as if something in his mind and
brain felt something had happened and
only something happened it's roughly
where it happened but that information
was not available to his conscious mind
he's never pushing a button that he says
he saw it he always says nothing I'm
waiting for something to come on and if
it comes on as a good field he responds
does that make sense okay but something
seemed to do it and when they found them
it was better than chance in the left
visual field he about things like if
they put on a bigger patch of lights he
could tell if you got a gave him a short
line or a long line now he would never
say I see the line you would have to
make him make a guess so the it would
you know when you read the papers it's
something like I don't see anything I
don't see anything
well you must guess is that
short line or a long line I don't say
there's no basis for me to guess it'll
be a completely random guess but you
know you must guess okay short or long
and then if the lines are far enough
apart in size he's almost 100% 97%
accurate okay if he's forced to guess
but he never has the experience that he
sees a line he just forced to guess and
told it it's two lines or he can judge
things like is it a circle or a cross
isn't an X or an O but he can't do
something like a square versus a
rectangle it's very limited subjectively
he always feels he sees nothing if he's
given two choices he's for some things
he can make the correct choice if he's
forced to make a guess and there's
another there's other sophisticated ways
again to show that even though he's
unconscious if anything in his blind
field something in his mind and brain is
processing information there so here
they had a thing where he pushed a
button when a light came on this is his
good field and it takes him on average
359 milliseconds okay now they do the
same thing this is this good field but
they put on at the same time a light in
his blind field and when they do that
his time goes up by about a tenth of a
second as if the distraction in the
blind field was slightly distracting him
from making that button press so another
objective way of demonstrating that some
information is being processed in the
blind field even though he never says he
feels like something's happening there
so here's an one more patient and the
last one I'll show you of this kind who
had the unfortunate occurrence of having
two strokes one in the left occipital
cortex and one in the right occipital
cortex about 36 days apart okay so now
he was blind in both fields by the time
he had both of his strokes so he had a
very unlucky person here in dark is the
missing cortex that is a died away
now always the problems with humans is
the injuries are not controlled and
precise and so here's two examples one
in monkeys an incredibly clever
experiment to get a monkey to tell you
what he or she is thinking about okay
and then one with infants as well human
infants I mean how do you get a monkey
to talk to you about their subjective
experience right the striking thing
about blind sight is the person who's
saying I see nothing I see nothing I
didn't see nothing even as he walks past
obstacles with precision and carefulness
right so here what it is they took
monkeys and may unilateral lesions in
them when there's a control monkey and
three where they surgically removed
carry you knows precisely as they could
the left occipital visual cortex and the
corpus callosum that connects the left
and the right and the first task and
I'll show you a moment was to touch a
light when it comes on and the second
half is the clever design to get the
monkey to tell you what he or jisub's
he or she subjectively feels is going on
so here's here's here's the video they
would make of the monkey and in one case
here's the light coming on so the
monkeys had left removal so this is the
Blind Side here's these bars show you
how often they point correctly to a
light going on and under this
circumstance forced to point forced to
point here's the control animal and you
can see that the animals were blind in
the in this field do almost perfectly
when they're forced to point they pick
almost perfectly which stimulus comes on
in the blind field okay now as they add
one more thing to the experiment they
have a number of lights and on the good
side here is a response that they can
push to signal I saw nothing and if they
truly saw nothing they get the juice
reward you know for which they're
working for okay but there's a light
that can come on here and the
Bradfield's in the right side now what
happens here is the control monkey doing
perfectly well for lights on this side
lights on this side and when nothing is
happening pushing this bar to signal
that nothing is happening sometimes no
light comes on so now the monkeys a lot
to say I see nothing by pushing this big
panel up here
think seems to have turned on but look
what happens to the monkeys with the
with the cortical lesions on the left
when this light comes on they almost
never say they saw it they almost always
push I saw nothing when they're allowed
to say I saw nothing by the response
then even though this thing that you
know they can see because you see here
they're responding perfectly well over
here but when they're allowed to sort of
consciously respond what they see then
these black bars are all the way down
they almost never indicate they saw
something they almost always pick the
response I saw nothing okay so the
monkeys telling you what is subjective
experiences which is like the humans
with the cortical lesions the reporting
they see nothing okay even though some
part of their brain can pick it up how
about in humans well so sometimes humans
children infants for medical reasons
have to have hemispherectomy x' in the
first year so these are unfortunate
infants who have severe brain injury
severe epilepsy and is considered better
to help them by removing an entire
hemisphere than to let to have them the
severity of the epilepsy they're having
these are rare cases of very unfortunate
in offense and in these infants who got
this for purely medical reasons to make
their lives better they also did an
experiment to show you something not
only about I think again what happens in
our conscious visual system but how that
system grows in infancy so and the
growth of a conscious cortical visual
system so here's what they did
infants this young because they're in
their first year can't even point and
you can't tell them to point right so
again you have to be clever
experimentally and what they did is they
watched where their eyes moved and
recorded that information and that was
the behavior sometimes they would have a
fixation you always have a fixation
you're looking in the middle and then
something would come on on this side or
this side in the blind field or in the
intact field okay and they would see how
often with her eyes moved to a stimulus
in their good field which they expected
all the time but how often would have
moved to the stimulus in the blind field
the eye movement then they had a
competition condition where you have a
dot in the middle and
fixation dot would stay on well its box
appeared here or here so the only sense
that the only difference between these
two is there's a dot in the middle that
can compete for what you look at that
makes it okay it's a veer it's not a big
competition it's just a boring dot that
stays on but there's a big consequence
so here's how often they move their eyes
to the target in a non competition
condition that dot goes on it goes off
and the box comes on in you're good
field or you're bad field and all these
bars are up at the top
I'm practically every trial at eight
weeks ten weeks and twelve weeks of age
the infant moves his or her eyes to the
stimulus whether it's in the blind field
or the good field so something in their
mind and brain is letting them identify
something and move their eyes to the
good field much like we talked about
before for the adults now in the
competition condition you can already
see it's not quite the same if there's a
dot on and the box comes on their blind
field they don't always make it to the
box that dot is sort of capturing their
conscious cortical attention and
diminishing the likelihood they notice
the box coming on in the blind field and
as a week's pass from eight to ten to
twelve just a month of development look
what happens as far goes from a little
lower a lot lower near zero that is from
eight to twelve weeks what it looks like
is happening is that as the cortical
system is and the infant's consciousness
is growing in some sense now it's no
longer tending to process the
information in the blind field if
there's competition right because the
growth of that consciousness in the
cortex is suppressing unconscious the
the ability of the infant to communicate
with unconscious systems or be guided by
unconscious systems in the brain so the
cool thing is the implication of this is
all of us have you know this colliculus
system in us it's a visual system that's
been around long through evolution all
of us have this massive conscious
Janicki list right the one goes into
your cortex system and that dominates
this other system and so you know we
only see it revealed in these patients
as guiding behavior
but you know who knows what it really
does in us okay because it's sort of
quietly sitting there
we don't have conscious access to it and
who knows how much is guiding our
behavior and it's very hard to figure
that out
but but it's definitely sort of
disappearing from our conscious life
within the first couple of months of our
development so now I'm going to switch
to the second major disorder we'll talk
about attention and neglect and go
through an igneous spectacular version
of that disorder something about how is
behaviorally measured its brain basis
and then a few more analyses but in the
book there's a very nice chapter about
these patients now patients with
blindsight are extremely rare you have
to have exactly the right kind of engine
you know to have to damage a lot of your
occipital cortex and those kinds of
injuries rarely occur on that scale
attention and neglect what I'm about to
describe to you if any of you become
physicians or work in hospital settings
you were guarantee see guarantee do you
see this a lot okay a lot it's very very
common for patients who have had things
like stroke or brain injuries of some
kind or another and a pretty typical
example is from Oliver Sacks most of the
sacs cases are pretty rare prosit big
nose you have pretty rare neglect
incredibly common in the hospital award
a neurology service so here he talks
about a woman an intelligent woman in
her 60s massive stroke affecting deeper
in her back bushes of her right cerebral
hemisphere good intelligence and humor
and what happens to her when they bring
her her dessert or coffee on her tray in
the hospital he actually complains that
she's not getting enough food because
she's only eating food on the right half
of her plates okay the left half of the
plate it's as if it were imprisoned for
her when they say but mrs. s it is right
there on the left she seems not to
understand what they say and does not
look to the left if her head is gently
turned so the dessert comes into sight
and the preserved right half of her
field she says oh there it is it wasn't
there before you understand you know
it's this is if the left half of the
plate did not exist and if they swivel
her head and now that left half of her
plate is in her right field
okay now she goes oh my gosh
hoots enough that on my plates and I'm
now I can finish my meal okay that's not
just that she also only puts on makeup
on half her face looking in the mirror
which can lead to comical you know
impressions okay so it's not she not she
ignores the left half of her world and
it's not that it isn't there it says if
it couldn't be there it's as if like
what are you talking about there's a
left half of something you know I see
everything okay so we'll talk a little
about this and understand more of it
coming up so neglect means is a failure
to report respond to report to something
that's opposite to the lesion
contralateral means opposite to the
lesion that can't be kind of for by
simple things these patients don't have
primary visual problems that not they
understand language they're paying
attention they're the ones who deny the
left half of their body they dress on
one side they eat from one side of the
plate and they also have something that
I'll show you in a moment the example of
because it's it comes back a couple
times and this sounds fancy but it's
simple there's extinction two double
simultaneous stimulation seen in the
late stages so here's what the
neurologist does and you'll see at least
one they're all just doing this in a
film clip coming up and they do this all
the time in the hospital though with
their little fingers they'll try to get
in the middle of the patient this isn't
carefully controlled but I've done on
the bedside so whether one side and say
do you see anything moving or the other
side and sometimes they wiggle both and
the typical respondents and neglect is
already fascinating so past the earliest
stages of the disorder they'll notice
the thing on the left side that's there
from their perspective that's their
neglected side they'll notice it on the
right side that's their good side okay
they're noticing this figure wiggling
you're not seeing that figure wiggling
but when the physician Wiggles both
fingers at the same time then the
patient will only notice the one on the
good side it's as if this is
extinguished because this one grabs your
attention okay and you know they could
see it by itself so it's only when it's
both sides then it's extinguished and
we'll come back to that so it's kind of
interesting it's not that their mind
can't see it but when there's
competition in the two fields which
reminds you a little bit of Blind Side
then their mind can't see it
so a strong fascinating and rarer piece
of this but again not not very rare is
something called a no signor Zia where
they not only had the neglect that I
just described but they have they deny
any problem at all so typically these
are patients of the big right lesions
about 5% of neglect cases and a very
fascinating neuroscientist you may have
read some of this stuff it's he's a very
creative mind Ramachandran at UCSD did
some semi experiments with some of these
patients so these are patients with
right-sided lesions it says they have
weakness or non-use of their left hand
and so here says dialogue with them can
you use your right hand and that
patients hand is fine yes can you use
your left hand yes that the patient
can't use her left hand
are your hands equally strong yes can
you point to my nose with your right
hand and she does her right hand is fine
can you point to my nose with your left
hand the paralyzed left hand it's the
left hand because there's a right
hemisphere stroke does not move at all
are you pointing to my nose yes
can you clearly see it pointing yes it's
about two inches from your nose can you
clap of course I can clap and here's
what she does okay are you clapping yes
I'm clapping okay she can't move her
left side but in every way in this
patients reports she seems to then deny
in a deep sense that there's any problem
in her performance or any weakness of
any kind so he wanted to do a couple
little experiments to to show that um
that you know that it's not just that
they're saying it but they'll follow all
the way through so imagine that you had
injured your left arm was in a cast and
somebody asked you yeah I'm gonna give
you two choices I'm gonna give you five
dollars to screw in a light bulb
your left arm is in a cast meow or $10
to tie your shoelaces which would you
take the light bulb right because it's
gonna be hard to tie your shoelaces with
one arm out of action this person is the
same way she said a stroke her left arms
not functioning she should definitely
take the you know definitely take the
light bulb she takes
shoelaces it is when the physician
Ramesh Chandra describes as she sits
there with one hand trying to flop the
laces together making no progress at all
okay he says finally he has to end the
exercise he can't take it anymore
she just she'll just keep going you know
until right so so it says she said she
just doesn't process that her left side
of her body is not working and then he
does another experiment more impressive
I couldn't use one of these I think okay
so imagine this was a tray of cocktail
glasses full of water let's say to that
very brim but imagine there's three here
and through six things right you can see
that you're right at the top and you're
just hoping that the person bring it to
you doesn't spill it on you and the
person brings it over to you
we actually filled with water and asks a
patient to hold the tray okay can I pick
on you for one second imagine you had
only how would you how would you hold
the tray if one arm was unavailable for
you okay I'm bringing this over okay
it's like yeah the wife's like very
exciting was watered yes okay all right
how would you had it if two hands were
available to you okay thank you okay
right you could it's easy for you to
imagine how you told it they walk over
to the patient with all stuff they
handed to her and what does the patient
do she puts out her right hand on the
right side and the whole thing falls
over all right they're trying to
demonstrate there's the you know it goes
all the way through this person really
believes there's not a problem and they
can be doused in water for a moment and
I'm sure tried appropriately and still
deny that there's any problem at all now
one thing they can do and this is kind
of a weird line of research but there's
a number of papers that show this is if
they put and I'm not recommending you do
this at home because actually it's worse
than it sounds like they take a syringe
with cold water and they put it into the
left ear the images here
the patients are starts to move they get
nystagmus and they ask them if they feel
how do they feel and Jen she says my ear
is very cold but other than that I'm
fine okay so she actually but they've
sort of given her a little bit of a
shock in the left ear and now he does
the interesting experiment do you feel
okay
she says her ear is cold can you use
your hands at this moment when they sort
of done something in the left ear that
sort of way
except the opposite right hemisphere I
can use my right arm but not my left arm
I want to move it but it doesn't move
this happens just in a moment from the
cold syringe in your ear whose arm is
this holding up the paralyzed arm it's
mine of course can you use it
no it's paralyzed like what kind of
doctor do I have right here it's
paralyzed course now here's something
really fun in a Sherlock Holmes Ian
sense how long has your arm been
paralyzed due to start just now because
what he's asking is does she have a
memory somewhere in her mind of her
entire experience or did she say it's
just started right now I don't know how
this happens it's not working and she
says it's been paralysed for several
days now about 19 minutes later when
they redo this she's back to just how
she was so they can temporarily
alleviate this by this irrigation to the
ear so this the denial of sort of you
the left half of your body this denial
that you have any disorder whatsoever is
a very striking thing and most patients
it clears up this is not you saw
pictures of for Melissa you saw movies
of patients with object disorders those
don't clear up
beylin syndrome special disorders those
don't clear up this NS leg nausea
patients grow out of as somehow their
brains recover over time but again it
shows you how much attention is
constructed right because they have the
stuff to represent their arm their
disease that's all in their mind and
brain but the state they're in because
of the brain injury lets them not
construct that reality so now I'm gonna
show you measures of neglect this is
your list just for your notes but sort
of fun just to look at the examples so
here's a patient where these patients
are typically have right-sided lesions
so the neglect is to the left half of
the world and here's a patient going to
the bathroom as if all you can do is
make right turns okay instead of going
this way as if the world weren't there
to proceed on the left
here's another test that happens every
day in a hospital they're given the
physician has drawn these lines and says
cross out the lines it's not perfect the
patient does that one but look at they
cross out all these lines and they the
left half ones are mostly left uncrossed
it's as if they weren't there here's
what's called a cancellation test
there's lots of letters here and their
jobs to cross out all the A's now let me
start with a neglect you see over here
this whole area nothing a circle
crossed out and you could say well what
would happen if instead of neglect you
were like one of those blindside
patients who have big lesion in the
cortex and you were blind on one side
what would you do there well it's easy
for those patients because what they do
is they don't see part of the world but
whether they do they turn their head
okay just like you would do right they
turn their head okay they don't see it
but they know they don't see it and they
turn their head and the patient was
blind on one side lost in the visual
field gets all the lines that's all you
have to do if you're blind on one side
is turn your head okay it's not that
hard in a practical sense but if you
don't imagine the left half of the world
exists where would you turn your head to
and that's what these and neglect
patients don't imagine the left half of
the world exists so here's a example of
a patient reading a text they're handed
this text the broken the slash lines
here are where this patient seems to
think the left side of the page stops
okay so they're overcoming everything
they know about how a sentence would be
and reading this passage the patient
says had to pass the windows whom good
morning message for the ground his with
all his and he bottle thank you very
much okay it's right in front of him but
you know the left half of the page is
just not present for this person's mind
here is a person copying a flower the
psychologist or neurologist draws this
flower or has a flower ready to go
drawing over and says copy everything
you see it's not that always totally
perfect exactly how it works but you
could see you know there's a lot of the
left side of this flower missing right
in front of them it's a very simple one
to copy everything you see here and what
they see is these three things up here
their jobs to copy everything down here
they have all the time they want left
side is neglected and all the copies the
triangle that's all they draw and the
the tester will always say are you done
are you sure you're done the person says
I'm sure I'm done thank you very much
sometimes they do something remarkable
they're shown a scene like this here's
four trees in a house in the middle and
you can see this patient is sort of you
know starts over here I said oh there's
a tree over here draw us this oh there's
a house
we're here and they jump from location
to location every time their attention
lands their draw the right half of it
okay it's always as if the left piece
we're missing and again this idea of how
constructed this is here's two more
examples and the clock thing we'll talk
a fair bit about here's a patient
writing to dictation the first sentence
they sort of stay up but now is as if
they were running out of room on the
page it's like the reading but it's
writing okay the left half of the page
doesn't exist clocks are used allotted
in this line because it's kind of
impressive and we'll come back in a
couple different versions about this but
look at that they were asked to draw the
time on a clock and it's as if they
could draw the time on the right side
their good side but is this the left
half of the clock didn't exist here's
another patient asked to draw the time
and you see almost what seems like a
struggle in the patient right they start
on the right side and then here they're
running out of space the guy crammed in
that tenant their mind knows it goes to
12 right but there's no space to put it
in and so you put them in a sense in a
sense of conflict and that's the top
version the bottom they were given
numbers of one at a time they were given
it tells you here twelve and six so they
put those in the right spots
here comes eleven already eleven is like
uh-oh right yeah then I'm gonna get you
know for nine you know nine is not going
to make it in ten you know they know it
has to come after you can see that
you've put them actually kind of in a in
a struggle between what they know the
something about where the numbers how to
go with the impossibility the left half
existing but now here's something and
we'll come back to this in a few minutes
what happens if you just give them a
piece of paper and say write down one
o'clock and then you take that piece of
the paper away write down two o'clock
take that piece of paper with then look
six seven eight nine ten those are not
bad right if they just do one of them
the very same patient who had to crowd
everything on the right it's quite
comfortable than putting on a pretty
good nine ten and eleven okay if it's
just one of them we'll come back to in a
little bit experiments that sort of help
understand what's going on in the 60s
because we don't all only want a
scientist to say wow this is
unbelievable and amazing right we'd like
to say something more about how the mind
is do
this what part of the brain is enjoyment
and kind of impressively here's a
patient with eyes open mostly crowding
on the right got that 10 on the left but
doing a better job when their eyes are
closed they miss the dial altogether
their eyes are closed but they actually
do the same patient does a better job
right okay so how does that work and one
more thing to mention is that neglect
occurs across modalities that is when
these patients have neglect I focused on
the visual but these patients also don't
do very well if they're doing things
like reaching for things and it's not
just vision it's pretty much everything
in the left half of the world and you
can do these kinds of things which again
show but not only their neglect but the
constructed psychological nature of the
neglect it's not it varies in ways that
are interesting so they're given a line
like this and say mark the exact middle
you would draw something here say I draw
here because they're going to neglect
that part of the line then they say read
the a so you're so draw the persist
entity and now draw it and they get
better then they're asked to mark the
middle not too good mark the middle but
you see the difference here the a is
present or the B is present and with the
B as president sort of pulls them over
here if the a is president sort of pulls
their attention over here they put their
hand at the middle and say now please
mark the middle their hand goes over
here for the middle but as they start
them all the way over here their hand
will only go this far so as you see all
these different movements is telling you
that the mind is kind of interpreting
what the world is out there you could if
you pull a little bit the person to the
left they'll notice a little bit more of
the left where is the injury and so
almost everywhere you read in still in
Neurology books to this day that it's in
the parietal cortex but in the last few
years people have mostly come to this
idea that the damage tends to be in the
temporal lobe and what happens when the
temporal lobe is injured it sort of
knocks off the balance of attention in
the left and right parietal cortex and
the sort of the there's something about
the activity in the right parietal
cortex goes way down that's paying
attention to the left half of the world
and as patients recover from this the
balance come back and that's actually
been measured now by brain imaging but
as their attention comes back clinically
and does in most patients
then the the balance between the two
parietal cortices get re-established so
even though people thought the site of
damage was here the interpretation is
usually here in the temporal lobe but
the consequence of that is reduced
activity in this part of the brain even
if it's not physically injured
so the fantastic thing is think about
this for a second
in order to ignore the left half of a
flower the left half of a design the
left half of a page like half of a clock
what do you have to know where the left
and right are it's not as if his eyes
were closed if your eyes were closed you
wouldn't know where left and right are
on a page right he has to represent in
his mind what is left and right
reasonably accurately and then he
extinguishes awareness that anything on
the Left could exist but part of his
mind has to know what is left for that
to work right otherwise the digits would
be all over the piece of paper not even
on the paper he centers on the paper he
centers on the circle right centering
means I know what's left in other words
that's the center and then BOOM the
leftist disappears as a place that could
exist so these are all tasks in front of
you there's been some incredibly you
know Sherlock Holmes like clever
experiments asking whether you also
neglect your imagination not what's in
front of you but your imagination so
here's the way they did it have any of
you been in Milan there's okay there's
like a central Cathedral and part of
town right this is a big okay deal
and so he took Milanese patience people
who lived in Milan their whole lives who
had strokes in the right hemisphere
who'd neglect any ask them to imagine
the Piazza del Duomo the major church
they're looking at it from one side of
the square or from entering from the
opposite side of the square
so okay all right and then I'll show the
other experiment here's the idea they
said imagine that you're entering the
square this direction so that the church
is behind you or this directions for the
church is in front of you so you're
entering the square from one side or
from the other side now the square that
you've been to many times that you know
very well tell me everything that's in
the square is you imagine entering from
one side and here's what the patient
reports they're imagining coming out
facing the church and they report these
kinds of things from this side if that's
only on the right side they're ignoring
the thing so they say there's a cafe
there's a bookstore or whatever else
there is here that's everything that's
in the square everything that's in the
square that's shown in red everything
that's in the square they wait just
moments and they say now imagine
you were coming out from the church
right opposite view of the square tell
me everything that's in the square and
here's what they tell you the items that
are in blue and they don't tell you the
items they just told you the locations
they just told you circled in red so
they're sitting there imagining them
they're square and then they will ignore
everything on their left whatever is
their subjective left and you know they
know it because all they have to do is
imagine they're the opposite side of the
square and then they report it okay does
that make sense they're ignoring the
left half of what they imagine the
square looks like one they've been to
many times and there's another patient
doing exactly the same thing
imagine you're coming out of the church
what's in the square well here's some
specific places I know that's it that's
it
wait a minute imagine you come this way
into the square facing the church what
do you what what's everything in the
square and they only report the things
on this side okay so they're ignored
yeah never do it's an excellent question
they just answered a moment ago one side
right why don't they tell you I just
told you this stuff on the other side
because it's as if it couldn't exist
right I mean it's it's a little bit
analogous to the patient whose arm isn't
moving and you go you know you have any
problem to go no I don't have any
problem it's as if that couldn't be a
problem you know like what are you
talking about right so it overcomes all
their knowledge and all their
intelligence it's you know it's as if I
forced you to guess in detail what's in
the back of the room if something new is
there and you go there's no way there's
no I can't see in the eyes I have no
eyes in the back of my head you know
that's what it's sort of like that it's
as if the left-half couldn't exist the
contradiction they could note right just
a moment ago I told you the other one
they don't notice it because something
about this neglect swallows up all your
judgments it's not as it's as
beautifully phrased you know by some
neurologists this it's as if the left
half could not exist at them whenever
you're thinking left it doesn't exist
and ironically you have to think left
for that to work right you know that's
that's that's the amazing thing you have
to go I'm in the middle there's a left
there's a right now the left doesn't
exist and it couldn't exist and any
every hint I get that it does
like that is you know there's food on
that side or you know the pages usually
go all the way here and makes the
sentence doesn't make sense it all
disappears on you because it couldn't
possibly exist and the neat thing about
that is you know striking neurologically
but that means in our own heads as we go
around we're constructing the world this
way you know building up too hot to uh
sides of our brain that are gluing
together a picture of the world around
us and these patients lose that glue on
one side of their brain is that okay
here's another version it served less
flashy a bit but it's the same idea
now neglect can't get small enough okay
if you make something very tiny then you
don't ignore the left side but once he
gets tiny enough you can't do it
so they took advantage of that and they
show cloud-like stimulus of these but
they didn't show them like this they
only had a slit so you only saw the
cloud a bit at a time and you see one
cloud and then you see another cloud
perhaps you see this cloud go by and
then you see this cloud go by and your
job was to say where the identical
clouds are not and if they were not at a
nickel on which side do they differ so
because you're all your visual
experiences through the slit which is
too small for neglect to happen what you
do is you create in your mind's eye what
does that whole cloud look like as a
passionate slip in your mind's eye and
then you see another one and you put
that up in your mind's eye and you
compare these two things that are in
your imagination in your mind's eyes and
what happens is if these two things
differ on the left side the patient's
rarely can make that distinction okay
it's not because they can't see it it's
always in that narrow slit but once they
put the pieces together they put it up
in their mind the left half disappears
on them in their mind's eyes
so here's an experimental approach to
think about what might be going wrong in
these patients so they used a very
simple task which is when a light comes
on you push a button that's all the task
is up any light comes on you push a
button and sometimes they'll put an
arrow and they're not and sometimes you
have no information the light comes on
on the left or the right and sometimes
they'll put on an arrow in the middle
that will warn you whether the light is
light likely to come on to the left
the right so sometimes you have neutral
things you get a cross in the middle and
light comes on you know if it's a left
and right you just push a button when
this goes on sometimes he gets an arrow
that's called valid that 80% of the time
if it's pointing this way he will turn
out on that side 80% it will turn out on
this side so 80% time is honest and 20%
of the time is dishonest so here's what
it looks like you're looking here on a
computer display that thing disappears
and then either an X is here or here and
you push a button that's all or light
comes on you just push a button okay
that's all you came on the left or the
right I push a button when an arrow
appears 80% of the time it's warning you
where that light will appear 20% it's
dishonest and it appears on the opposite
side so you will know how good an
experimental psychologist you are right
now if I ask you which condition do you
think you're the fastest to push the
button when you have an arrow that's
truly telling you where the light will
come on and the arrow that's misleading
you or the X that tells you nothing
which do you think you'll be fastest
where the arrow is pointing directly
here's the answer over here okay thank
you very much sure all right
which do you think you'll be slowest on
the dishonest arrow right here Oh sis
look over here look over here and you're
looking over there oh no it came on the
other side you lied to me okay all right
and the X is in the middle and here's
the data and it's a very simple
experiment right how fast are you this
is reaction time just to push a button
when it comes on here's the neutral
condition in the middle you're a little
bit faster if it's a an honest arrow
you're a little bit slower if it's a
dishonest misleading arrow so now you do
this exact experiment and I'll show you
the data and then I'll simplify it for
you okay
with patients who have right-sided
damage left side and neglect
and you can see as you look at these
lines that the arrow can be honest or
dishonest then it can be in the left or
right side now if you're always bad on
the on the neglected side you go well
that's not a big surprise but here's a
surprise patients were only bad don't
the times were way up here only when
they had a dishonest arrow that sent
them into their good side that's when
they were really bad
so let's take a look this again so
here's the bad side here's the good side
when that arrow comes on that's honest
good when an arrow comes on that's an
honest arrow this way they do fine
that's a bad feel but they do fine tiny
bit slower but just a tiny bit arrow
comes on that moves them into their bad
field but it's really the lightest on
here they do fine but if an arrow sends
them into their good field then they're
really really slow to get back here so
Posner's argue that when you move your
attention in the world you have three
steps you have to do you have to
disengage your attention from where
you're paying attention just logically
I'm paying attention here right now I'm
gonna pay attention over here I've to
pull myself up from here move my
attention over here and then focus here
so he doesn't get you know get out from
where you are move to where you need to
go and land and focus what you want to
do and the only condition where they're
bad is where they have to get their
attention out of the good field as this
once they're in that good field once
their mind has landed in that good field
they're in quicksand
and it's gonna be really hard to get
their attention to move into the bad
field so think about this ik locks are
perfect for this because when you draw a
clock mostly think about this
intuitively if I were to ask you to draw
the numbers on a clock you start with a
12 typically then what's the next one
you would draw one because that's how
we're taught to do clocks disaster if
you have neglect you know you're in the
good field right now the left half of
the clock has disappeared on you and you
got it because the clock has made you
land your attention on the good field
and now you can't pull out of it
okay but what happens if you only have
to draw eight o'clock your attention
never got moved into the good field it's
just starting from middle so to speak
and this very same patient can draw the
eight o'clock or ten o'clock
pretty well that makes sense because
they never got stuck in the good field
they only moved into the bad field they
can move into the bad field and and so
so and if their eyes are closed that's
better they get less stuck and now we
understand this thing why is it these
patients if both fingers are moving
because once their attention is drawn
into the good field it's as if the bad
feel disappeared on them but if they
only get stimulated in the bad field
right side here then they're okay
because they never paid that much
attention to the good field so they
can't so this is a nice experiment it
shows you what is the problem the
problem is once you pay attention to the
good field a normal healthy field it's
so powerful compared to the weakened
representation here that you never leave
it because it just seems like everything
now here's here's a clearly clever one
again this shows you how much of a
tension is created by our minds as
opposed to just simply defined by the
environment so what if you show it
display to somebody with neglect and
then rotate the display right in front
of them okay
so initially the neglect is going to be
the left side but imagine the thing is
turning over like this right in front of
them will the neglect travel with the
initial assignment so this is from
Marlene Burnham and a very clever
experiment they have to pay attention to
light comes on here or here but what
they do is while the experiments going
on right in front of you slowly rotates
over to here and sure enough then the
light comes on
sure enough the neglect now moves into
the good field because once you've
assigned left and right you know this is
left so ok you turn it over that's still
really left ok the mop but think how
weird that is the mind is deciding that
in an absolute sense this thing is on
the right but the mind said this is the
leftward one and you can flip it over
but you're not tricking me you know I
know it's on the left and I'm
considering it the leftward one right
the mind is deciding what counts as left
and right not the world and what other
kinds of processes you know information
is being processed
that's not reaching tensional level so
here's a cute experiment they would say
to these patients you know any
difference between these two things
no but if you have to live in one of
these houses which one do you think
you'd live well I don't know they're
pretty much the same why would I pick
one I'll pick one okay they got a little
better place to live if I have to pick
one you know which of Oz do you want I
don't know they look the same right have
to pick pick this one okay which glass
to drink from
have to pick pick this one says they
don't consciously are not aware of
what's going on here when there's
information to the opposite side to draw
their attention but something in their
mind somewhere is picking up information
so the last question and I'll show you a
final video is this what kind of
information is picked up in the
neglected field as you decide some part
of your mind to neglect it so imagine if
I showed you two forks versus a fork and
a spoon okay in order for that to make a
difference whether you report both our
presence so again if you have a
right-sided lesion you might tend not to
report this fork or not to report this
key if you just don't report either one
okay left is left and you're bad at
reporting that when there's something
competing in the good field right your
attention gets drawn here hard to
disengage but if it makes a difference
what this thing is that means right that
your mind kind of knows what it is and
your mind is saying you know well if
it's a key that's a different enough
that I can still pay attention to it but
if it's another fork well those are
really similar and now my mind is really
sucked into this fork but in order for
that to make a difference does it make
do you see that you have to know
somewhere in your mind what's different
than the left okay for that to affect
performance
so now we'll see a video of a patient
the last one this is a neurologist Bob
Rafael and a patient you know it's a
hugely nice thing of the patients most
of all but also the physicians to make
these tapes available for teaching
purpose
so say you understand just for just
review for
and we're done that when the same object
came up that he pretty much noticed the
one on the bad side on the right side
for him no right same object he almost
always said it's one if they're
different objects he typically reported
slightly sluggishly the one on his bad
side that means part of his mind has to
know what the object is so that he
ignores it if it's identical and he
reports it if it's different well you
have to know what it is to base your
answer on that yet the logic of neglect
is that if they're identical that he's
going to ignore the one that he spotted
on the left and part of his mind but
squashed from his awareness and the
other side okay thanks very much
you